in our series the 2020s you believe that
we're exploring the big topics that will
dominate the conversation in the next
decade well today our focus is on
climate change over the last 10 years
sea levels have risen at an alarming
rate biodiversity is reportedly
declining faster than that of any time
in human history and millions millions
of people have been affected by extreme
weather like hurricanes and floods as
2019 ends this year is likely to be one
of the hottest on record so what can we
expect over the next decade CBS News
meteorologist and climate specialists
Jeff bird Ellie is here to explain how
are you this morning doing great I know
we hear climate change we do think doom
and gloom the world's coming to an end
relatively quickly but what are some of
the technological advancements and
innovation should we be looking at to
help improve the issue of climate change
so this is the best part right sometimes
you go to the doctor and the doctor says
I'm sorry there's not much I can do for
you
right we know the answer and the answer
is to move away from fossil fuels and
start leaning on sustainable energy and
here's the best part the more we use
sustainable energy which is you know
this energy that's given to us by the
Sun and the wind it is free the more
that the prices go down of that the more
we have to create vast industries and
vast employment and opportunities for
ourselves so the bottom line is that we
can create a better life for ourselves
so we don't have to look at this as a
death sentence or doom and gloom right
we can look at this as a time that we
can create a brand new and better future
with better jobs higher paying jobs so
just to give you an idea for every one
job in fossil fuels to create one unit
of energy you need two or three of those
jobs in solar power and the
fastest-growing opportunities in the
next decade number one is wind
technician number two solar technician
think about that benefit the economy
benefit the environment and make it
clean we've talked before on the
Saturday show about this but the Arctic
and the Amazon seem to be the two areas
with the biggest change that we're
seeing ahead so these are tipping points
we need to watch them closely the Amazon
it's being slashed and
very quickly climate change is drying it
out and if we don't if we're not careful
it could turn into a savanna so from a
rainforest with all that life into a
savanna
right now it's acting as a carbon sink
it's pulling tons of carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere it is helping us slow
down the consequences of climate change
pretty soon it may not be able to do
that same thing with the Arctic and
permafrost permafrost is frozen ground
in the Arctic tundra that now this year
has changed from being a net absorber of
carbon dioxide to being a net emitter
which means that it causes climate
change to spiral and go even faster and
we have to watch out for destabilization
of ice shelves in the Arctic and
Antarctic something we hope doesn't
happen but if it does sea level creeps
up even faster alright Geoff Barrow
Delly thank you so much next week in our
2020 series we'll explore the next
decade and health and what advancements
we could see
you